good morning it gets Tuesday so when I
was in Ethiopia I got to talk to this
young girl who's clinging to her brother
and I learned that her mom went to
Kuwait to work and her dad works in the
city so her grandpa takes care of them
she told me that she missed her mom and
that she worried that her brother might
have pneumonia and the way this
beautiful girl held her brother just
shattered me and eventually I looked
away in fact a lot of my footage from
Ethiopia is of me looking away we drive
up to the hospital past families
desperate to get their loved ones good
care and I look away I turned the camera
toward preterm babies struggling to
survive under not good enough heat lamps
and then I turn away and then there was
this little boy too thin very sick
life-threatening ly sick with diarrhea
who was the same age as my own son who
had the same sweet way of getting into a
chair that's too big for him while
outside his mother waited nervously for
a diagnosis for some help and I looked
away while she waited to find out if he
had malaria I filmed this beautiful
Vista now I think this was partly
because even though these people all
gave me permission to film them these
moments felt very private but it was
also hard to watch it's hard to see kids
suffer and mothers worry and to feel
powerless before it and it's hard
because these are problems that I was
unaccustomed to I mean the poor are
voiceless in too much of our
contemporary discourse this kid's mom
doesn't have a Twitter or a youtube
channel and so we don't hear about her
challenges as directly as we hear about
others maybe that's part of what makes
it easier to look away to but regardless
I kept doing it I have hours of footage
of my camera looking away I spent all
this time in Ethiopia and what I
videotaped most was my shoes I talked
before about how much there is to be
excited about in Ethiopia child death
has dropped by more than two-thirds in
20 years and that's amazing as is the
huge growth in school attendance rates
and a growing number of college
graduates but Ethiopia is still one of
the poorest countries in the world
malnutrition is common and almost half
of Ethiopians don't have access to clean
water which is probably why that boy was
so sick in the first place so I
understand this urge to look away but I
think to change the world we must
grapple with it as we find it I want to
live in a world where children don't die
of diarrhea and malaria where they
aren't malnourished where they can drink
clean water and the world I want to live
in won't come about by me looking away
the problem egg is that if we only look
away it's hard to listen and it is
through listening that we can learn how
to actually help rather than just
imposing upon other
our ideas for what they need this woman
a member of the women's health army told
me that she has to walk miles twice a
week to fill jerry cans with drinking
water and dirty river water is used for
washing when I asked her what her
community needed most she answered
immediately water health care worker
abdulqadir said the same explaining that
it was hard to deliver babies without
water to keep everyone clean this health
care outpost worker these women this
grandfather they all cited water as
among their most basic needs so ok let's
not look away let's listen I talked to
water org and they set up a fund raiser
for the nerdfighter community all the
money raised will go towards sustainable
water solutions for people in Ethiopia
and if we raise $100,000 in the next 10
days Bill Gates will personally match
our donation so every dollar we donate
will count as - and if we reach our goal
we can get safe water to 8,000 people
now that's not a solution Hank it's not
going to end poverty or childhood
mortality but it can change the lives of
those 8,000 people so if you can donate
please do atwater org slash John Green
there's also a link in the doobly-doo
Hank here's to trying to learn to listen
and not to look away I'll see you on
Friday